I left one thing out when I said that
the dot prototype objects that come for
free on functions were just as
uninteresting as any other new object
that we could use for storing methods in
fact these prototype objects come with
one extra convenience property that
almost no other object has every dot
prototype object has a dot constructor
property which points back to the
function it came attached to thus there
is a mutual linking between any new
function and its companion dot prototype
object because car links to that
prototype object and prototype links
back to the car object car dot prototype
dot constructor is car itself the main
use for this feature is so that you can
figure out which constructor function
built a certain object all instances of
a class delegate their failed lookups to
their prototype and so they should all
report as having the same constructor
function what do you think would be
logged as a meze constructor property